OK, this this story is a headache and there's
just so much to talk about.
So let's let's do it in detail and kind of
do it.
Justice Donald Trump surface from the hole
in which he's been hiding for weeks yesterday
to deliver a four minute speech about the
covid relief package, which we deeply criticized
yesterday for its many flaws and its erroneous
elements.
And I would say there's a two sided coin to
Donald Trump's four minute speech.
There's things he said I agree with and things
that he said that I disagree with.
But it's actually much worse than that.
It's like a four sided coin that you would
be using on a chessboard while playing for
each other.
I mean, I don't have a metaphor to really
explain the erratic and confused nature of
what Donald Trump said yesterday.
So rather than tell you in advance, let's
just start going through it.
Some aspects of this four minute statement
are completely deranged.
And at the same time, Donald Trump correctly
said six hundred dollars per person is not
enough.
I would like to see two thousand dollars per
person.
That's great.
But this was still a wacky, lie riddled fiasco.
So let's go through it all.
You will also notice Donald Trump doesn't
look or sound good, slurring a lot.
That thing where he's tripping over his tongue
almost like his teeth are too big or his tongue
is getting in the way worse than we saw before
the election.
So let's just jump right into it.
We're going to look at the full four minutes.
Throughout the summer, Democrats cruelly blocked
covid relief legislation in an effort to advance
their extreme left wing agenda and influence
the election.
So this is already a lie.
I mean, Democrats proposed more relief months
ago before the summer.
Mitch McConnell said we're not doing another
relief bill.
Trump was MIA every once in a while saying,
well, there's negotiation.
So so that's just an absolute lie.
Democrats, almost immediately after the first
bill were proposing even including two thousand
dollars per month like our friend Rohana.
Let's continue.
Then a few months ago, Congress started negotiations
on a new package to get urgently needed help
to the American people.
It's taken forever.
However, the bill they are now planning to
send back to my desk is much different than
anticipated.
It really is a disgrace.
For example, among the more than 5000 pages
in this bill, which nobody in Congress has
read because of its length and complexity.
It's called the covid Relief Bill, but it
has almost nothing to do with covid.
OK, now Trump is correct.
The bill is outrageously long.
Members of Congress didn't have time to read
it.
And tons of it has nothing to do with covid.
But it's not that the covid bill has nothing
to do with covid.
Remember, they were wrapped up together a
funding of government bill and the covid bill
1500 pages and were given everything to vote
on together.
So Trump is right that there wasn't enough
time, but he's now starting to get into one
of the big deceptions of the speech.
Let's continue.
This bill contains eighty five point five
dollars billion for assistance to Cambodia.
One hundred and thirty four million dollars
to Burma, one point three billion dollars
for Egypt and the Egyptian military, which
will go out and buy almost exclusively Russian
military equipment.
Twenty five million dollars for democracy
and gender programs in Pakistan.
Five hundred and five million dollars to Belize,
Costa Rica, El Salvador, Guatemala, Honduras,
Nicaragua and Panama.
Forty million dollars for the Kennedy Center
in Washington, D.C., which is not even open
for business.
One billion dollars for the Smithsonian and
an additional one hundred and fifty four dollars
million for the National Gallery of Art.
Likewise, these facilities are essentially
not open.
Seven million dollars for reef fish management.
Twenty five billion dollars to combat Asian
carp, 2.5 million dollars to count the number
of amberjack fish in the Gulf of Mexico, a
provision to promote the breeding of fish
in federal hatcheries.
Three million dollars in poultry production
technology.
Two million dollars to research the impact
of downed trees.
Five hundred and sixty six dollars million
for construction projects at the FBI.
OK, so.
So this this is this is now where it goes
completely off the rails.
First of all, Trump only mentions countries
he doesn't care for or sort of like asshole
countries, countries he doesn't think we should
give money to.
And he mentions climate and environment related
stuff that he also doesn't care for.
And I want to be careful because this is two
sided.
None of that stuff is part of the covid bill.
Remember, they had two bills together.
This was like an omnibus.
You had the funding of government and you
had covid.
And in the funding of government, you have
aid and money designated for different countries.
Now, it's not really the covid bill.
Does Trump know that?
I don't know the answer to that.
There are lots of people who fell for the
idea that a lot of these things are in the
covid bill when they're not.
Trump could be lying in order to make a political
point or I don't know.
But Trump himself may not really like Trump,
may just be watching Newsmax, Fox or whatever,
and he may be falling for the idea that the
funding is in the covid bill.
I don't know.
I really don't know the answer.
Now, in fairness, overall, when you look at
the totality of what's going on here, Donald
Trump is simultaneously stumbling across some
important critiques of the system like Trump.
Doesn't this it's so insane if Trump instead
of just saying we're giving money to Pakistan
and for carp or whatever, if he were to say
and sort of also mentioning 5500 pages, they
didn't have time to look at it.
If instead he said these two bills shouldn't
even be together, the covid bill should be
simple.
It should be a standalone bill.
It should have been shorter.
People should have been able to it should
have been short enough that everybody can
actually look at it and then separately deal
with this other bill.
That would be a really good critique of how
politics is done.
Instead, Trump goes almost into his xenophobic
stuff of listing countries we shouldn't be
giving money to.
And then he builds on that by going into the
immigration stuff.
The bill also allows stimulus checks for the
family members of illegal aliens, allowing
them to get up to one thousand eight hundred
dollars each.
This is far more than the Americans are given
now.
This is really deceptive.
Trump's claim is that Americans get 600 dollars,
but illegal immigrants get eight hundred dollars.
That's just not true.
OK, and let's see if I can explain this.
What is true is that if you are a U.S. citizen
or a legal permanent resident with a green
card, you get six hundred dollars and you
get the six hundred dollars.
Even if your spouse or partner is here illegally,
OK, the spouse or partner doesn't get six
hundred dollars.
Undocumented immigrants don't get any money.
You don't lose your 600 dollars if your spouse
or partner is an undocumented immigrant and.
If you are here legally and you have kids
here, you get the six hundred dollars per
kid, even if your spouse or partner is an
undocumented immigrant, so so Trump saying
illegal immigrants get more money than Americans
is wrong in a bunch of different ways.
The point is, being with an undocumented immigrant
does not preclude you as a legal citizen or
resident from getting six hundred dollars
for yourself or the six hundred dollars per
child.
It's a completely fabricated way to attack
immigrants.
Let's continue.
Despite all of this wasteful spending and
much more than 900 billion dollar package
provides hardworking taxpayers with only 600
dollars each in relief payments and not enough
money is given to small businesses and in
particular restaurants whose owners have suffered
so grievously they were only given a deduction.
For others to use in business their restaurant
for two years, this two year period must be
withdrawn, which will allow the owners to
obtain financing and get their restaurants
back in condition.
Congress can terminated at a much later date,
but two years is not acceptable.
It's not enough.
Now, this is where I find Trump to be saying
some things correctly.
And this is why the populist rhetoric can
be so tricky and so pernicious.
Trump is saying 600 dollars isn't enough and
there isn't enough for small businesses like
restaurants.
I agree.
That's correct.
But it's all wrapped up in lies and xenophobia.
But on that point, I agree.
And Donald Trump actually makes a couple more
good points.
Congress found plenty of money for foreign
countries, lobbyists and special interests
while sending the bare minimum to the American
people who need it.
It wasn't their fault.
It was China's fault, not their fault.
I am asking Congress to amend this bill and
increase the ridiculously low six hundred
dollars to two thousand dollars or four thousand
dollars for a couple.
I'm also asking Congress to immediately get
rid of the wasteful and unnecessary items
from this legislation.
So Trump wants two thousand dollars, not six
hundred dollars.
That number happens to be exactly what people
like Rossana Congressmen have been asking
for for months, including when Trump claimed,
oh, Democrats didn't negotiate.
And he said that at the very start of the
speech, this is all backwards.
And along those lines, Trump now complaining
about all these countries getting money, Egypt,
etc.. Trump asked for those countries to get
money in his budget, but now he's saying the
problem is they're getting the money in the
covid bill, which they're really not.
They're getting it in the bill that was voted
on in in conjunction with the covid bill.
So it's all lies.
And then now Trump on the number of dollars
per person, happens to pick the exact number
that many Democrats were asking for.
Two thousand dollars.
And immediately many Democrats jumping and
saying, great, we'll rewrite it right now
and put in 2000 dollars that it doesn't.
Republicans don't want that, but we're glad
to do that.
So Trump is right on some aspects here, but
he's a liar and he's completely disingenuous.
And then now the rap with Donald Trump threatening
to veto and he just can't help himself.
He has to throw in.
Maybe he will actually be the person sworn
in this January 20th and not Joe Biden.
And to send me a suitable bill or else the
next administration will have to deliver a
covid relief package.
And maybe that administration will be me and
we will get it done.
Thank you very much.
He cannot help himself.
He at any event, no matter what it's about,
he has to say it might be me who gets that
second term on January 20th, not Joe Biden.
So the big picture is if Trump does veto it,
nobody gets a penny.
And that's the risk right now.
Let's call Trump's bluff.
Trump says he wants to grand rewrite the bill.
Democrats say you want to do the two grand
and put it on Republicans to say no.
If Trump really is serious about he wants
two grand per person, Democrats are ready
to do it and make it be Mitch McConnell or
whoever is going to come out and say, no,
no, no, no, no, we don't want to do the two
grand.
So we'll see what the next 24 hours bring
if this ends up getting people 2000 instead
of six hundred dollars, even as disingenuous
and dishonest and clueless as Trump is, I'll
be I'll be glad.
And remember, I'm getting zero.
I'm not negotiating for myself.
I'm not getting any money from this.
But remember, there were two bills here funding
government and covid.
And if it's vetoed, not only do people get
nothing, we may even end up with another government
shutdown.
Who knows what happens then in terms of transition,
in terms of so many different things.
But we'll we'll deal with that if and when
it becomes an issue.
Remember that on January one, twenty twenty
one, we have a one day membership special
going on.
If you've been thinking of grabbing a membership
at join Pakman Dotcom, but you want a completely
disgusting, immoral discount with which to
do it.
One one twenty one is the day.
If you want to be notified of this great membership
special, just get on our newsletter.
You can sign up at David Pakman Dotcom and
January 1st you will get a perfect email from
me telling you exactly how to sign up
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.